hello everyone my name is Matt uh today
we're talking about deploying Basque so
I've worked on desk for a long time I'm
one of the maintainers and
oops sorry
yeah
um on the maintainers and a conversation
I often have is if you're talking to
someone say hey use desk it's easy it's
fun and someone says like yes I love
desk go desk hopefully you are also this
person uh if you're not if you've never
heard of Das before it's probably not
gonna be the right talk for you you
should like leave this session go off to
YouTube there's thousands of talks on
Das today
mostly today we're going to talk about
the next question which is how do I
deploy tasks securely or in a nice
robust way
so what comes after you say you really
like to ask how do you actually get it
running an organization
this will applies to any other
distributed computing framework like
spark otherwise
so
I've done this a lot a lot of different
people eventually made a company uh
coiled which makes it really easy to
deploy to ask and I say try coiled it's
easy and cheap people say no I'll do
this myself even cheaper uh and this is
you know an interesting conversation I
have
um
and mostly my response to this is it
might not be as easy as you think
deploying distributed systems inside of
large companies is challenging
and so this talk I want to give a talk
which is really about this this question
you know it's actually it's a
challenging thing to deploy a
distributed computing framework robustly
inside of an organization that is both
sort of safe for I.T and is also
Pleasant to use
um it's often you get sort of one or the
other but not both
so this is what I call a classic Iceberg
problem it seems really small at first
you think I can deploy things I know how
to use kubernetes I know how to use the
cloud
and so it seems really small but as you
get closer and closer to the problem it
actually gets pretty big and I've talked
a lot of people who sort of run into the
sort of like the bottom of the iceberg
so I want to educate folks about what
the sort of the bottom of the iceberg is
deploying distributed systems is not
just borrowing machines from the cloud
or HPC it's can I connect this machine
securely can I turn them off reliably
can I manage costs
um can I ship software to those machines
um and that's where things get a little
bit complicated so we're going to go
through and sort of learn a little bit
more about a lot of the bottom of the
iceberg topics hopefully this will help
you as you're thinking yourself about
how you deploy systems yourself
so this talk will be in three parts
it'll be a desk example I would like to
start with a sort of a more flashy
example
then you're going to learn more about
the problem about that bottom of the
iceberg
and then we'll learn about some
solutions so I've got my own solution
that I pitch but I also sort of sent out
some emails to other people who have
similar Solutions and try to get some
information about a few of them so
hopefully you can see some some other
ways which we'll have solving this kind
of problem
so first let's look at an example so
I a couple weeks ago was looking at the
work of my colleague James warbeau and
James is trying to get dasc integrated
to a library for hyperpreneur
organization called up tuna
and it's a cool Library by the folks of
preferred Networks
makes it easy to do hyper parameter
optimization uh we see a lot of people
using desk and I'll tune it together we
wanted to make it easier
and so I wanted to try out James's work
and so I I downloaded Altoona I cloned
it I checked out his branch and I
installed it locally
and I'm gonna ask for a dash cluster
that runs that software
um and we're gonna sort of get a bunch
of machines in the cloud
I'm using coiled here as our service but
you could use lots of things to do this
and we're going to play with an example
and we're going to refer back to this
example frequently in the talk and if
you sort of are sort of watching along
you might guess the kind of things I'm
going to talk about
so what's going on here so I'm asking
for 20 machines with two cores each
using the software I have locally
and it has notice I've got like a
locally edited version of Altoona and
it's packaged that up
and then it has provisioned a bunch of
machines so there's one machine
supervisioning but the 19 are the rest
are done
so when I see provisioning I mean that
we are asking the cloud AWS in this case
for for 20 Machines of two cores each
looks like it's been giving us T3 medium
instances
those machines then booted so they're
installing Ubuntu they're turning on the
power is coming on I'm getting access to
them
and now those machines are on those
machines are been rented it took about
20 to 30 seconds when you get those
machines
now I'm installing software into those
machines right I am you know installing
xgboost I'm installing optuna I'm
installing Das I'm installing python
now I've got my machines so I can go and
I can play with with that system
so from my my MacBook here or my works
on a Mac Mini
I'm connected up to that cluster
and I'm going to use you know
some code that a colleague of mine at
Nvidia had written to do sort of equity
boost training
and then we're going to see that you
know to ask an optuna and extra boost
are all playing together and I'm sort of
doing lots of things in parallel if
you've seen a desk talk before you know
how to interpret these graphs on the
right
but you know I'm doing lots of machine
learning stuff in parallel on these
machines I just rented
and then when they finish I'll get some
some nice results so I'm able to sort of
experiment here with my colleagues work
with James's work
and it was nice I'm able to sort of like
play with something live and see how it
performs I'm seeing it perform nicely I
actually like that this is pretty easy
the code I had to write to hyperhampton
optimization was not that complicated
now that it's done I can go and I can
you know look at some opportunity things
actually don't really know how to
interpret these plots but maybe you do
as a machine learning person
so cool I got a thing it worked I can
report back to James that it worked well
I then went and looked a little bit at
performance
um and I noticed that we're only
spending a very small amount of our time
actually training xgboost and most of
our time is doing like administrative
Optima coordination work
as this concerned me like I'm trying out
this development workflow and it's
actually not as good as I thought it was
I was able to dig a little bit deeper
deeper
and so I I sent James a message right
this is a couple weeks ago I said hey
James I'm trying this out in the wild
and you know workers are working
something that doesn't seem quite right
so I sent him actually like a
performance report so he can go and you
can look at the same thing that I just
did and you can say that so you can see
that same profile
I then like 20 minutes later I like put
a print statement into my my code and
ran it again I said like hey like I'm
seeing things that are kind of strange
so uh this all happened a couple weeks
ago James made some changes and I'm
happy to announce that things are now
merged so Altoona now has task support
or we'll have to ask support in the next
release
but this gives you a sense for how
people operate in the wild with
something like dasc uh at scale with
normal code right this isn't a canned
example this is actually like a pretty
live example
so that's my example we're going to
refer back to this a few times as we're
thinking about all the things that
needed to exist in order for me to be
able to do this well
so now I'm going to switch to
so again the stock is in three parts one
at a sample we've just seen we've seen
tasks do machine learning at scale on
the cloud it was great
um and I've learned about all the
problems of setting that up and that'll
be the bulk of the talk and then we'll
see some solutions that's some things
that solve some of these problems
oh what kind of problems are we looking
at what's the bottom of that Iceberg
talk about borrowing machines installing
software connecting to those machines
securely observability and user and cost
management
I'm gonna go through these things as
quickly as I can so we have some time
for questions at the end so borrowing
machines
uh you're always going to rely on some
kind of resource manager to borrow
machines you could install disk manually
on a bunch of machines you have in your
basement but you probably don't want to
do that probably rely on some other
technology like kubernetes or the cloud
or an HPC job scheduler
and typically what you're going to do is
you're going to in Python ask for a
number of machines a number of CPUs
number amount of memory and then some
desk library is going to translate that
into some sort of request for the
underlying job manager so here if I'm
using Das kubernetes I get a kubernetes
yaml spec if I'm using something like
Das cloud provider which talks to the
cloud I'll use some kind of boto or ec2
or AWS API
if I'm using an HPC job scheduler I'll
just get translated to a job script
if you're using one of these systems one
of those three things was familiar with
you and the other two weren't
but what's nice about that these are all
the same API and they have different
backends so it's easy to migrate from
say HPC to Cloud
and we saw this also with up here right
I asked for
you know I asked for 20 machines with
two cores each and I got a bunch of you
know T3 mediums right
so what's
so I don't know what system you have Das
can run on that system and that's nice
and desk runs on like lots of systems
like if you're using digitalocean or if
you're in Europe using hetzner if you're
on MPI there's there's a task system for
you
but this is just the top tip of the
iceberg right just like barring machines
is the is the easy part of deploying
disk and even this gets pretty
complicated right like often people
don't just want CPUs and memory they
want you know they're using disk and
they find that the disk that it's
default is really bad they want fast
ssds or they want gpus you know first
they want t4s and they want a100 that's
because they're doing training
or they're doing spot because they want
to reduce prices and they want to select
select a certain you know availability
Zone in a certain region
this gets pretty complicated pretty
quickly
um and we often have people who just
like set up kubernetes and assume
they'll be fine and actually things get
pretty hairy pretty pretty fast
moving on I was borrowing machines let's
talk a little bit about installing
software
so
on my machine I've got some libraries
what you saw I've got XG boosts I was
playing with Hub tuna I was playing with
pandas so now we got to get those
machines over a wire to all my machines
running desk somehow right how do I do
that
um
uh
and this can be a variety of different
things that I care about moving software
it can be the operating system this
actually honestly doesn't matter that
much like I'm using a Mac here and I'm
connecting to Linux machines and
everything's fine
it could be system libraries it can be
python itself right do the versions
match if I've got python 311 locally and
python37 remotely the play doesn't work
very well
there's things like pip and condo
packages which most systems think about
so you know my own custom code my
private code be it probably go to
packages locally editable packages right
we saw what I was playing here with this
like Git Version of opt tuna so there's
lots of different sort of levels of
software that I need to send over and
make sure that they match
and this can be kind of challenging
um it's especially challenging these
sort of bottom bits that are a bit more
rapidly changing uh some systems don't
handle these well and this is actually
pretty important to give me this kind of
Rapid development cycle that I'm looking
for
so any system you're going to use want
to solve this in some way and different
systems handle it in different ways
if you're on an HPC like a big Iron
system like IBM or you're running slurm
or PBS or crit engine you probably have
a network file system and this is
actually magic like this actually works
super well
um there's like a bit of software that
make sure that all the machine seeks all
the same software everywhere
this is a really good development
experience these system was usually
really old and they're being sort of
retired which is a shame because this is
really the best development experience a
shared network fossils everywhere solves
lots of problems
um for the rest of us there's Docker and
Docker tends to be the de facto standard
that we see to ship software around
Docker is great it's a great technology
it does introduce this sort of like
this uh piece in development cycle where
you're editing a Docker file you're
building a Docker image you're pushing
it out container Repository
and you do that every single time you
make a change right and so I mentioned
that I was sort of in my development
cycle I then like added a print
statement into my code to see if
something was wrong and I ran the
experiment again if I had to do that
every time I make a change this gets
challenging
uh Docker is a really good tool for
stability across time and across
machines it's actually pretty bad tool
for dynamism
um it's not very good for sort of
interactive workflows
so
um anyway as you're thinking about
installing software this is probably the
second biggest thing people think about
after borrowing machines
and many people think about these sort
of top pieces how do I get the right
conda and pip packages onto the remote
machines and the answer is usually
docker
but people should also think about and
you're going to need to think about how
do you handle these this bottom part of
that stack
uh local packages local scripts Dynamic
functions
so software distribution is still an
open problem there actually aren't uh
very good solutions to this yet I
actually want to point briefly to a
couple pieces of technology I like
uh condo store here at the link at the
bottom made by the folks at quantite
I'll talk about it briefly later but the
cool self-contained system that helps to
deploy packages and also prefix the
developers have made Mamba the condo
alternative recently started a company
it's very new very young I want to take
a look at them sort of they'll sort of
solve something in the space in the
future
oh
um
moving on network access so we've
borrowed some machines we've installed
software in those machines
can we verify that we can talk to those
machines and they can talk to each other
in a way that's secure that's cheap
that's safe
and so how this works we've got some
local machine right here on my example
I'm running this notebook a stupid
notebook on my laptop
and I'm connecting to this remote Das
cluster sitting in the cloud over the
open internet right and how do I verify
that for example you can't also connect
to that Das cluster
by default Das connects over TCP if
you've used Das before you've probably
seen addresses that look like this
those addresses are fine but they are
insecure right and that's actually
totally fine there aren't that many
people kind of hunting around the
internet searching for open Das clusters
we've written in a secure organization
this will probably become an issue
because other people could also connect
to that same desk cluster they could be
you know using your credentials they
could be accessing your data they could
be you know changing your data
the the most common way to solve this is
uh by using secure connections and by
Distributing uh TLS Keys everywhere uh
the first project to do this is Das
Gateway desk away is also an excellent
way to deploy Das on kubernetes or other
systems
uh that's gonna be another proxy your
connections or it can sort of broker a
connection for you again setting up TLS
everywhere
usually you have some system that lets
everybody know who the Gateway is and
how to trust them so there's not some
other you know Phantom Gateway
pretending uh this allows you to stop
other machines be able to connect to
your scheduler or other workers to
connect to the cluster in a nefarious
way or even other gateways trying to
pretend to be the the Gateway
depends all this you also need some kind
of user database that can tell who's who
this might be active directory this
might be some intermediate service like
key cloak what we often see with sort of
more open sources groups is they use
Jupiter Hub which is a pretty
lightweight user database system
so if you want to handle security you
have to have a sort of architecture
diagram that looks something like this
um that's you know you don't need to do
this you can stay sort of insecure for a
while and that's fine I think many
people even at very large institutions
stay insecure for a while
so it's probably fine but if you sort of
want to go Whole Hog you'll need to
think about these kinds of things
so moving on to observability so we
talked about again borrowing machines
installing software connecting the
machines well
how about observability so stuff broke
what happened
right and we saw this in my example
right I ran some stuff
I looked at profiles I said oh this
doesn't this doesn't seem right
and so I sent something to my colleague
James I sent him first this performance
report
and then I like made a change and I said
hey look here go look at some logs
I was able to point him to a historical
results right
um
and it's really nice to be able to do
this right I don't have to sort of have
a live session to show them things
I can sort of Point him to what's
actually going on in the world
and this is really useful right the kind
of observability thing it helps me work
with my colleagues
and find something that works well for
all of us
um
so why do you care about visnerability
we've seen logs people say hey look
things broke this is most of my life
someone tells me is gas broke and I have
to figure out what happened
another common case just a few weeks ago
I was talking to a large user group that
doesn't use any kind of platform or
they've built their own platform
and I say hey look you should upgrade to
his version of task the new version of
dasc is way better for you it solves
lost problems your users are facing
right now
but hey look we actually are afraid
about upgrading because our current
workflows might break we've got users
who are using this thing and we don't
want to sort of break them say great
let's go and assess all the active
workloads and see what they're doing
I actually had no ability to do this
they actually had no idea who was using
desk the annuity who is using their
platform
or they did but it was buried somewhere
they didn't have good access to
and so Telemetry informs decision making
right can I use new things can I retire
things can I fix things that are broken
unfortunately Das provides a lot of
telemetry right so there's very basic
things like logs which any system will
provide
and these should go into some kind of
log aggregation service right probably
datadog or cloudwatch or somewhere that
you can get access to them
uh you know Das also provides a lot of
sort of performance Telemetry right ask
I'm sorry dask has
knowledge about how much money you spent
parsing CSE files and how much S3
bandwidth you're using and how much
internode bandwidth you're using
and this kind of information aggregated
across all of our users at all time can
really inform a lot of sort of cost
cutting measures a lot of Performance
Tuning measures a lot of sort of
tracking who's having issues
um it's really valuable
um you should be tracking some of this
information somewhere
a lightweight way of doing that is with
Prometheus
so dasc and many other systems publish
Prometheus metrics
throwing those into a Time series
database and putting something like
grafana on them can really help you
understand what's going on in your
system across your organization
um let's see
yeah so Telemetry saves lives at least
debugging time
the last thing I want to mention is
users and cost uh the like basic
question people want to ask is you know
why am I spending money who's spending
that money you know how do I turn things
off there's a lot of waste in any large
deployment that we've seen if you go to
like a customer talking about about
their databricks bill it's like
probably only 10 useful things about 90
waste and people especially large
organizations are really
um curious about to make this better
the like simplest question is did I turn
everything off uh this is actually a
source of a lot of anxiety for new users
um and often you think you did but you
actually left things on
um I've done this I think everyone that
I've seen used the cloud has left things
on
in fact Jacob Tomlinson are sort of the
like task maintainer that thinks most
about deployment things are probably one
of the scariest problems we have today
so you want to be able to ask questions
like what's costing you money right uh
how much money are we spending so this
is a trace of one of our internal
benchmarking accounts by the money we
spend per week just doing benchmarking
and you know there's things here that
I'm curious about as a business owner
and I want to see what's going on 500 in
a day is it's fine but it's you know
it's an FTE
um I might want to attract attribute
those costs to individual users here's
you know Ian spent about a couple of
compute weeks a few weeks ago in a day
um what was he doing at the time and
what was happening this day right was
everybody off was the system down
you sort of want to get some more of
this information and then once you sort
of can sort of map your trust to
different users you want to start to
think about controlling those limits
right how do you reduce that spend how
do you how do you constrain that spend
so I just went very rapidly through a
bunch of things you're going to want to
think about in deploying any kind of
distributed computing framework
let's talk about some solutions right so
we talk about some problems borrowing
machines installing software connecting
securely observability and cost
management
there's some platforms which solve these
problems or try to solve some of these
problems for you
I'm going to talk through a few of them
so I asked these folks for
um for slides of the nabari folks
actually gave me the best lives when I
spent the most time with them and then
I'll talk about coiled which is my bias
where I work
so there's a project called qhub which
is a bunch of Open Source tools
including desk all bundled together
qhub recently rebranded to nabari so if
you're familiar with qhub sort of
mentally shift your your thinking
this comes out of a great company called
quantite which has a lot of Open Source
work in the in the community
so nibari is a collection of software
open source software packages all
bundled together it's includes packages
like Jupiter prefect condom condom
management Prometheus grafana video chat
service I wasn't aware of uh and also
desk and so that's why I'm talking about
it today but they do lots of things so
you might consider them for lots of
different systems
Avari Works in sort of a git Ops or
infrastructure as code approach so you
provide a lot of yaml files that Define
the system that you want
they turn that configuration into
terraform and they deploy that for you
in whatever cloud or kubernetes system
that you have it's a really good way to
produce a nice sort of Jupiter data
science scalable platform Wherever You
Are
I'll mention a few packages inside of
their system there's Honda store which
sort of takes you know condo packages
pip packages and serves those up as
Docker images or or environments
They don't serve just Jupiter a common
concern we hear people do just Jupiter
they also provide proper Ides for actual
sort of software Engineers too
and also things like dashboard
development so they sort of thing about
the whole whole development cycle
so there's Saturn which is I'm actually
going to go through kind of for time
constraints we go through this quickly
Saturn does mostly the same thing uh
they bundle up a lot of Open Source
projects but they do so in a more AWS
focused way
same with kubeflow uh again the same
thing they sort of do the same thing on
kubernetes very kubernetes forward
uh most I want to point you out to here
is that
all right go ahead
great
um I want to point you to the desk
kubernetes topper which we released
recently uh that helps to ask a much
more kubernetes native security
kubernetes land think about kubeflow
think about nabari drawn to AWS think
about Saturn or think about coils so I
work on coiled a lot of Dash maintainers
work on coils
so briefly coil doesn't do what everyone
else does it doesn't bundle because a
lot of different packages quill thinks
just about desk so we focus very deeply
on dasc
and we allowed to integrate very well to
other systems
so for example in our example we saw
that I was playing with Jupiter on my
laptop
oops
on my laptop and connecting up to coiled
right so coil doesn't have coil
notebooks we just allow you to use quilt
from anywhere same with conda same with
prefect same with vs code gold is very
uh agnostic other Technologies to use
and we do ask very very well there's a
lot of nuance to doing this well we hear
a lot about this sort of interplay
between desk and the cloud
there's a lot of things to talk about
there's no single feature that's awesome
I'll mention a few things people that
users mention uh in the next couple of
minutes
first setup is Trivial
um You can count install it from conda
or pip you can log in with GitHub or
Google authentication is Trivial you can
set up so call deploys inside of your
own cloud we don't manage your
computation we instead like click the
right buttons in AWS for you
and then sort of broker a connection to
that system and then get out of the way
uh you can set up coiled either by going
to AWS console and the coil UI or from
your command line we actually have like
a pretty nice setup wizard that runs
everything about three minutes
once you're there you can run it from
anywhere
quality configurable you have a lot of
different machines and you can be
actually pretty prescriptive with where
you want those machines to live what
kind of machines you want what instance
types you want uh and you also like
support colleagues that don't understand
things
um I'm gonna pass through a bit of this
quickly just because it's taking some
time
uh we used to the same thing that
everyone else does where you can like
handle content and pit packages
we just found this kind of was kind of a
pain in the butt uh it's like really
hard to like specify your environment
this changes pretty frequently we found
and so we've actually shifted a thing
called packagesync which just like looks
your local environment packages it up
and ships it remotely all in about as
fast as you can do a Docker pull it's
actually a really nice piece of
technology we're pretty proud of it
um yeah I'll move past
finally costs uh there's actually a big
point of contention among users
apparently uh and coil is a lot of
classific measures I'll bring up one
here which is spot instances types so
this is a Time series showing a usage I
think one of our internal accounts and
the blue is are you such a spot and the
Orange is the reason on demand so we run
workflows on a regular basis we need
them to run
we want to use as much spot as we can
but fall back to On Demand this feature
is actually really well loved to be able
to sort of use spot when you can but
fall back to On Demand when you can't
and you can see we're getting a nice
blend most of the time this rectal
results is having far lower costs
we'll do things like crazily shut the
workers down when it sponsors go away or
choosing the right Zone where there's
the most spot that's available
there's like a dozen others cost saving
measures I can mention but this is one
it's neat it's a good example of knowing
dasc and the cloud well and that
interplay they're able to handle that
well
so that's it
um yeah zooming back out fast as easy
just playing it is easy until it's not
thanks for your time